That leads us to a very very simple kind
of musical instrument,
which just consists of
some blocks of wood.
If we look at this set of blocks of wood,
I think you can probably see that they're
all the same length,
they're all the same width,
but they vary in thickness,
at this end they're quite thin,
and at that end they're quite thick.
And so if I do something rather silly,
which is to drop them on the floor,
that's why they look so battered,
they are 120 years old,
if I drop them on the floor one en
will go down, hit the floor, bend,
and then because the wood is springy
it will spring back and back again,
and so it will make changes
in the air pressure
which are rather like the changes
that Gillian was making
when she was whistling.
And so we should get a sound,
nothing like as beautiful as the whistle,
but I think you'll be able to tell
that it is a musical sound.
And as we go to thicker blocks,
because they're harder to bend,
we shall find  that we get them
springing back quicker
and so we get a higher frequency.
So now I'm going to drop them on the floor.
[WOODEN CLATTERING SOUND,
MAKES MUSICAL SCALE]
I think you can hear that we have a scale.
[APPLAUSE]
Well of course that's a very
inconvenient instrument,
because we end up with all the blocks on the floor and you can't play it again
[LAUGHTER]
But nevertheless here's another version of
the same instrument,
which is designed not to play a scale,
but to play a little tune
and we'll try and hope you recognise it
[WOODEN CLATTERING SOUND,
PLAYS HARK! THE HERALD ANGELS SING]
Well I hope you recognise that.
[APPLAUSE]